-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and of course,
I send out thank you notes.
And I was just
running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you guys mind -- James,
can I get some thank you note
writing music, please?
♪♪
-"M3gan."
-Yeah.
No, it's not "M3gan."
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Dry January,
for being the month
where people go a whole week
without drinking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"What's the date?"
-"It's close enough."
♪♪
Thank you, Kevin McCarthy.
You know what they say,
if at first you don't succeed,
try, try, try, try,
try, try, try...
and try and try again.
And try and try.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Speaker of the House,
for sounding like a fancy name
for your Alexa.
[ Applause ]
"That's the speaker of --"
My kids changed the Alexa name
the other day.
-What is it?
-It was like Zippy
or something.
[ Laughter ]
It's terrible. It's a nightmare.
'Cause I go, "Why is
this not working?"
They go,
"We don't know anything."
But I guess you could
change the name.
So, I had to find out --
-So you have to go --
Did you have to say --
-"Zippy, can you change
your name back to Alexa?"
-But you had to know Zippy.
-Someone had to figure out
Zippy, yeah.
-Hey, man,
it's February 1st somewhere.
[ Light laughter ]
-Thank you, George Santos,
for being the Pinocchio
of politics.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Southwest Airlines,
for making people on Spirit
feel like they just got upgraded
to first class.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Up in the sky
with my champagne ♪
[ Air horns ]
♪♪
[ Deep voice ]
Spirit Airlines.
♪♪
-Thank you, ski lifts,
for not updating your safety
requirements since 1936.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Pull the pipe down.
Or don't."
-"Grab that rope."
-"Pull the pipe down, or don't.
We don't care."
♪♪
Thank you, tiny jugs
of maple syrup,
for looking like accessories
for an American Girl doll
moonshine kit.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You wanna try some of this?"
-"Yeah, the revolution's
coming."
-"Oh, this'll put hair
on your chest."
[ Light laughter ]
"You got it, pappy."
♪♪
-Thank you, "Avatar" sequel,
for being the only movie
where the positive
and negative reviews
both say, "It blue."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on.
♪♪
-Thank you, adding a heart
or a "ha ha" in a text message,
for being the nicest way to say,
"I want this conversation
to be over."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Ha ha."
♪♪
Thank you, Christmas trees
after the holidays,
for taking Dry January
way too far.
There you go, everybody.
Those are our thank you notes.
We'll be right back with
Allison Williams, everybody.
Come on back.